the opening scene features a boxer from
England named Billy Moore who is about
to engage in a boxing match it turns out
he has traveled all the way to Thailand
to make a living in the boxing sector
however just before Billy steps into the
ring he consumes a narcotic this
indicates that he is a hardcore addict
as the fight commences Billy's breathing
becomes increasingly labored due to the
narcotic despite his extensive
preparation and rigorous training his
efforts are ultimately foiled as his
opponent lands a devastating blow that
sends Billy crashing to the canvas thus
concluding the match however our brave
protagonist gets back up and demands
that they restart the fight in a moment
of frustration he even lashes out at the
referee and beats him up later that
night Billy seeks Solace at a local bar
where he encounters an individual who
offers him money in exchange for
Narcotics the following morning Ty law
enforcement officials pay a visit to
Billy's residence hearing their arrival
he hates instantly conceals all of his
narcotics within his undergarments but
despite his efforts the police managed
to place him under arrest and handcuff
him before tossing him onto a nearby
table Billy is then escorted to the
police station on charges of possessing
illegal substances the day after Billy
and several other prisoners are
transported to the notorious clong Prem
prison in Bangkok upon arrival they are
subjected to a thorough search including
a strip search and bodily frisking
subsequently Billy is directed towards
the mugshot area where a correctional
officer secretly slips in some heroin he
is then escorted to a cramped holding
cell where the other inmates are
shouting and making a Ruckus afterwards
an officer arrives to brief the inmates
on the prison rules he informs them that
gambling smoking and tattooing are all
awesome but are strictly prohibited and
violators will be subjected to harsh
punishment later on Billy moves towards
the crowd to fill his water bottle when
a fellow prisoner shoves him enraged
Billy prepares to retaliate but right
then several officers intervene and
escort him to his solitary confinement
cell the next day Billy is transferred
to a different cell which houses several
prisoners with tattoos covering their
entire bodies shortly after the leader
of the prisoners Kang summons Billy and
starts speaking in Thai which the latter
can barely comprehend I'm sorry gov I
don't follow following a brief exchange
Kang orders Billy to perform push-ups
while the other inmates taunt and harass
him this understandably aggravates Billy
but he is powerless to retaliate since
he is outnumbered and alone later on the
prisoners offer Billy a cigarette
without the guard's knowledge the same
night when the majority of the prisoners
are sleeping Billy walks towards the
toilet as he is about to take a leak
Kang and his associates Ambush him from
behind and hold him at knife point they
then force him to watch their assault on
an innocent prisoner the disturbing
incident takes a toll on Bill really
psyche preventing him from sleeping at
all that night the following morning
Billy is overcome with grief when he
learns that the innocent prisoner from
earlier has committed the unthinkable
distraught he goes to the infirmary and
requests pain medication but the officer
refuses to give him any Billy argues
that he has seen the other inmates
receiving free painkillers but the
officer retorts that the medications are
not free and demands money or cigarettes
as payment this causes Billy to lose his
cool prompting him to engage in a
physical altercation with the officers
during which he bites one of them on the
neck unfortunately other officers soon
arrive and beat him to a pop Billy is
then thrown into a cell with a [__]
and mate named Fame who assists him with
his injuries in the next scene Billy's
leg is cuffed to prevent him from
engaging in any further physical fights
afterwards during a communal bath with
the other inmates Kang's gang takes
advantage of the situation and lights up
a cigarette while hiding in a corner
they also offer billia stick of their
secret stash which he consumes covertly
that's the good stuff mate a few moments
later Billy expresses gratitude towards
Fame for assisting him the previous
night with his injuries as he asks for
some cigarettes she inquires if his
family deposits money into his account
to which he responds that he does not
have family he then borrows some
cigarettes from her and Promises to pay
her once he receives money in his
account the next week later that evening
Kang and the other prisoners are seen
gambling for cigarettes Billy also
trades his cigarette pack for Narcotics
as he has become desperate for them at
midnight the prison officers wake
everyone up and inform them that three
prisoners have been killed the prisoners
are then let outside for inspection
unfortunately a police dog smells
narcotics on Billy's clothes and when an
officer checks him he
stash Billy has taken aback but tries to
convince the officer that the clothes
aren't his he puts on the clothes just
to demonstrate that they are not his
size which somehow convinces the officer
as a result another inmate is punished
and Kang and his gang become angry that
their friend has been caught on the next
day Billy finds himself in a desperate
situation craving for another hit of
heroin he approaches a correction
officer hoping to score some narcotics
the officer agrees to help him and takes
him to an empty cell where he hands
Billy a cigarette stick laced with
Heroin surprisingly he even stands guard
while Billy takes the drug to ensure no
one catches him later while in the
bathroom as Billy is taking another hit
of heroin two fellow inmates suddenly
catch him they demand some of it and
threaten to punish him if he doesn't
oblige the situation quickly escalates
and they are about to attack Billy but
fortunately another inmate arrives and
defuses the tension the next day Billy
is back in his cell desperately looking
for the same correction officer to get
some more narcotics a while later the
officer arrives but this time he refuses
to give Billy any drugs because he
doesn't pay for it out of desperation
Billy agrees to do whatever the officer
asks and the latter orders him to
Assault The Two Chefs as they are bad
for his business Billy agrees without
any hesitation he first hits a stick
before proceeding to the kitchen where
he beats up the Two Chefs nearly killing
them after the violent incident the same
correction officer warns Billy not to
kill anyone and offers him narcotics as
a reward however Billy who has realized
the severity of his actions turns them
down overcome with guilt and despair he
then goes to the shower and starts
crying at night Billy has an emotional
breakdown and decides to commit the
unthinkable but luckily an inmate
notices his wound and immediately wraps
a cloth around it to stop the bleeding
then he calls for assistance hence
saving Billy's life later Billy is seen
inside is cell practicing his boxing
moves hoping to channel his energy and
emotions into a positive outlet his leg
coughs are later removed allowing him to
move more freely and he heads to a
boxing ring where other prisoners are
training despite his desire to join in
the instructor denies him permission
perhaps due to his violent past Billy
then visits Fame to apologize for not
repaying her he again requests for
another pack of cigarettes so that he
can give it to the instructor and join
the boxing team he also assures her that
he will prove himself and certainly
repair though hesitant fam hands him the
cigarettes allowing him to join the
boxing team where does Fame keep getting
these darts after joining the team the
instructor orders him to enter the ring
and fight one of the prisoners Billy
hasn't fought in a while and as a result
he's easily dominated by his opponent he
becomes disappointed in himself and is
further hurt when the other inmates mock
him hence from the following day he
begins his full day practice in order to
regain his boxing skills one night bill
observes the inmates playing a game of
betting cigarettes he decides to
participate bets two packs of cigarettes
and surprisingly wins the following day
Billy visits Fame in her mini store and
Returns the cigarettes he borrowed
earlier the two then start chatting and
Billy reveals that he has a father and
brothers curious he asks her why she is
in prison to which she confesses that
she killed her father because he used to
physically abuse her as they continue
talking their conversation eventually
turns into a romance one day Billy is
scheduled to fight another and made of
comparable strength the fight begins and
soon turns brutal but in the fourth
round Billy gains the upper hand and
knocks out his opponent with his
impeccable boxing skills gaining victory
for the first time in prison and in this
movie later the prison Warden preacher
who witnessed Billy's fight appears to
be impressed by his skills and summons
him to his cabin preacher then shares
his decision to send Billy to another
cell that consists of the boxing team
team granting him privileges furthermore
preacher says that he's the first
Foreigner to compete in National
Tournament qualifying hearing this Billy
becomes happy and also expresses his
gratitude for the prestigious
opportunity before the two depart preach
it informs him that he has only two
months for his training following this
Billy is transferred to another cell
where he receives good treatment from
his fellow inmates he also begins
rigorous training and preparation for
the upcoming tournament one day during a
meal his inmates share their stories
about how they ended up in prison one of
them reveals that he was in prison for
five years and due to the depression
caused by this he stabbed three prison
officers which has landed him an
additional 13 years he then goes on to
say that he joined the boxing team
because he occasionally gets a chance to
fight outside where he can see his
family for a few minutes come along kids
it's it's time to go watch your criminal
father beat the [__] out of somebody
again later Billy also agrees to get a
tattoo on his back as the days passed by
Billy's training goes very well he also
starts gaining back his confidence but
one day he catches Fame with another
prisoner this breaks his heart and as a
result he relapses on the narcotics he
also vents his rage on his boxing
partner in the ring because of this the
officers put him in an empty cell that
is larger than the previous ones Billy
spends the entire day working out and
practicing his boxing moves after a few
more days he is sent back to the boxing
team cell as soon as the officer leaves
his enraged boxing partner gets into him
however Billy reacts calmly and
apologizes for what he did earlier
considering his apology the boxing team
allows him to return to the ring and
also assists him in his training
eventually Billy forms strong bonds with
his fellow inmates one night the
ladyboys enter their cell and sing them
a love song throughout their performance
Fame keeps her gaze fixed on Billy
implying that she still has feelings for
him one day after training Billy is
taking a bath when King and his gang
approach him and to demand some money
for keeping their mouths shut regarding
his narcotic addiction Billy asks for
some time assuring them that he will win
the match and then pay them however the
gang covers his face and beats him up
before departing Kang threatens to
inject him with AIDS oh my God if he
loses the match unfortunately Billy
suffers from a hernia and upon receiving
treatment the doctor informs him that
the rupture is due to excessive intake
of Narcotics and that further trauma can
result in Death from internal bleeding
despite this Billy decides to fight so
he is transported to another prison
where the tournament will be held on the
competition day Billy practices with his
instructor one last time before heading
to the ring as the match begins both
boxers engage in a head-on fight
displaying exceptional skills at one
point the opponent's kick strikes hard
on Billy's abdomen causing him
excruciating pain the opponent also
commits a foul by kicking Billy while he
is down regardless us our protagonist
Bears the pain and fights on eventually
he manages to knock out his opponent
with a spinning back elbow prompting him
to win the match however his
celebrations are cut short as he
collapses on the ring after vomiting
blood later Billy wakes up in the
hospital and attempts to elude capture
by running away but after going a little
too far he realizes he should reconsider
his actions and gets back to the
hospital Billy is then transferred to
another prison where he meets his father
who proudly Smiles at him after serving
three years Billy is transferred to a UK
prison and is granted amnesty by the
king of Thailand why though